hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
smart plastics improving qpcr
reliability and reproducibility
my name is christy jewell i'm with
labrutz and i will be moderating today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab routes
and sponsored by eppendorf for more
information on our sponsor
please visit and click on the eppendorf
logo
on the left side of your screen now
before i begin i would like to encourage
you to engage with us
you can submit as many questions as you
want at any time you want during
the presentation simply type them into
the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
additionally we have a few polls for you
and we welcome your participation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
that support tab found at the top
right of your presentation window or
just use that ask a question box
and let us know you're experiencing a
problem today's presentation is
educational and it does offer continuing
education credits
following the presentation those credits
can be obtained by clicking on the tab
at the top right of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits
before i pass on this presentation to
our speakers i would like to point out
that you can read full biographies
on dr tim shaw martz dr michael poffel
and dr rafal gurskowiak gentlemen
the stage is yours
thank you very much for this nice
introduction christy
i am tim and as introduced i would like
to send out a warm welcome
from eppendorf for this educational
webinar
we are very happy that you all took the
time
to join us today for about
60 minutes so that we can give you some
insights on how to improve your qpcr
reliability and the influence of
consumables on
qpcr workflows we are
extremely honored that we are joined
today by
professor michael tuttle from the
technical university of munich
so we will start
with an introduction to the
meeker guidelines the relevance for
improving
qpcr is reproducibility and some
examples
and from that we will then continue to
take a deeper look into the influence of
consumables
on qpcr workflows
some tips and tricks what to look out
for
when choosing consumables and how to
handle with them
but first i would like to
get started with professor huffle
so i'm handing over to professor huffle
the stage is yours
thank you very much for this nice
introduction
and thank you very much out in the world
i
really appreciate it to take place in
this webinar
and what i want to talk for the next
let's say around about 10
to 15 minutes is about the mikey
guidelines
a short introduction the relevance and a
few examples
and let's start and the big question is
uh what is already on the market are
there quality control
strategies and standardization
initiatives
in genomics transcriptomics or molecular
testing
or even beyond and there are
some a lot of or let's say some
examples here it was the first one was
probably the miami
the standardization of hybridization
microarrays
then we have the mikey and the digital
nike guidelines they're dealing with
real-time pcr
our tq pcr and of course digital pcr
and there are a lot of consortiums
dealing with quality control
in ngs in next generation sequencing
and there are also initiatives from the
oecd
or who about testing
we as our group here in germany
are involved in the mikey guidelines and
also in standardization
in gs also how to get valid biomarker
signatures from liquid biopsies and how
to standardize
ngs and we published in this
area quite a few publications
so we have these quality problems
and reliable reliability problems as
well
today in sars testing and i want to
show you some comments which is uh which
are going around
uh this is uh some comments from the
european union where the commissar
complained about that we have been
working hard to analyze
information on the quality assurance of
the coronavirus testing
and devices that are currently being
used the results show that there is a
mismatch between the existing quality
and what could be expected to ensure the
good performance of the tests
so we have huge problem and also the
scientists
complaining that there might be false
negative results
one out of five samples during corona
testing
this is going quite abroad
through the press in in in uk where the
scientists
raised concern about quality control and
hence we got a position paper from
steven busting and tanya nolan also
courses of the mikey guidelines
about uh articupcr testing
and they they have a a big
concern about misinterpreting the
results of
corona testing so what is the big
question what is the central problem
in qpcr its undefined variability you
know it from your results as well
if you have various experimental group
or treatments
often you have single groups with high
arrow bars
or huge variability and the questions
where these variability is coming from
and hence i try to group these problem
areas in diagnostic pcr in three parts
so we have the pre-pcr parts the pcr and
the post pcr
and all of these uh groups
more or less impact uh the variability
and the reproducibility
in pcr so pre-pcr of course
a huge impact of sampling uh technique
sample quality the extraction quality
and extraction efficiency
of your nucleic acid then of course how
to prove it that
you have to be sure that the rna in the
dna quality
quantity and integrity and also purity
of your sample is of high integrity
and also the experimental design is very
important
jumping over to pcr of course protocol
cycling profile
meaning fast cycling rapid cycling
uh is has a huge impact and
often uh produces unspecific products or
even prima dimers
and now we are coming of uh more or less
to the topic of the day
consider how the consumables and
hardware are
impacting tube blades tip ceiling
robotics and so on they have a huge
impact on 0.7 the essay validation
meaning how specific is your
essay how sensitive do i come down to
a sensitivity of a few dozens of
molecules
how reproducible is my essay
in comparison to other labs to other
researchers or
in a worldwide ring testing and of
course there was
this limit of detection and
quantification
and also from point eight to thirteen
is what is more or less the impact of
post pcr
meaning what how can i increase my real
reliability after i perform
pcr how i handle the data
how i handle outliers the normalization
strategy
and so on and their own efficiency and
statistics at the very end
but today we are focusing on this point
consumables and hardware and how sis
reacts on essay validation
and represent reproducibility
so hence a bunch of researchers
were sitting together long long ago this
was i think we started 2007 to
2008 uh uh to to to to get also
collect all these problems and these are
12 researchers from
i can say all over the world uh most of
them are coming from from europe from
czech republic
uh england uh belarusian
sweden me from germany and of course a
stephen busting
first author and also carl vitra he's
the inventor of the
uh the light cycle system and and we
were sitting together
discussing what what do we need of
course we need guidelines so guidelines
the so-called monkey guidelines the
minimum information for publication of
quantitative real-time pcr
experiments but what does it mean what
what what is what does mikey stands for
and this is a set of guidelines that
describes the minimum information
necessary
for evaluating qpcr experiments
and the much much deeper and broader
goals are
to provide guidelines for all those
reviewers and editors
to measure really the technical quality
of the submitted
manuscript all the paper or the work
you've done to
establish a clear framework to conduct
qpcr experiments
it should support experimental
transparency
increase represent reproducibility in
your lab but also
between labs even worldwide and it
should promote
consistency more comparable and more
reliable results
and during these day also to standardize
the nomenclature
and to bring it to the point uh the
mikey guidelines should
increase the reliability of okpcr
results
and should ensure the integrity of
scientific work
of course is major focus on the
biological relevance
and if you see here on this slide it
worked it worked out
up to now we have these are very data
from the last weekend
we have now more than 9800 citation of
his paper
it means all these citations are coming
from the big
let's say academia countries like
united states germany europe united
kingdom
china and from all over the world you
see here a lot of countries
are using zmiki guidelines
so let's come to the content of the
monkey guidelines so
they are divided in nine
major headings we call it the mikey
checklist so these headings are
experimental designs here you you see
them well you actually you don't see
them uh but i hear
uh i i depicted it in a larger letter so
experimental design the sampling
nucleic acid extraction reverse
transcription and target information the
primers the protocol
essay validation and at the end the data
analysis and the statistics
and normally we got
we got information about
the pcr efficiency and we also got a lot
of information in the papers about the
normalization strategies about
the software use uh but the real pre
pcr protocol and the consumables used
in the in the assets are often forgotten
so hence i want to focus today on the
mikey checklist on
number seven on the pcr protocol and
here i want to focus here what is the
impact on the
plate tubes uh even if there's a
reaction setup
from a robot or is it manuel i would
just want to
uh point out these two points
and long ago 2008 we published a paper
about these and
this was effective plate position and
plate type
and ceiling system on real-time pcr this
is a paper from
2008 it's already 12 years old but
during these days
we were working uh uh with the master
cycler from eppendorf this was the days
where epidurf
was producing a real-time pcr machine so
we were also
had one of these machines and we want to
test it
there's the impact of white plates
versus transparent plates so we had
eight eight strips with white and with
transparent uh wells
here you see we set up or we assembled
kind of a virtual plate and a 96
setup with transparent white sections
uh and then we performed and all of
these we performed standard curves here
we have transparent white transparent
white
and you see depending on on on the the
white or the
transparent uh plate itself we receive
very nice standard curves all have a
high efficiency
with 93 94
a percent of pcr efficiency
the regression was good the slope was
good but if we go
deeper in the data we saw a huge
difference
between some samples here and some
samples there and if we divide
this we see that these samples are
coming from transparent plate and these
more or less as the amplification curve
is coming from white plates
all of all of these dilutions here
from left to right were always the same
concentrations from hundreds
thousands up to millions of copy and you
clearly see here the standard curve the
represent
reproducibility uh is is good but what i
want to point out is the information
output from these white plates and if
you look here on the data we call this
during these days the amplification
efficiency
in terms of increase per cycle and if we
have here
the so-called transparent we have here
hundreds or
in the hundreds and in the white plates
we have in the thousands
meaning we have a huge significant
increase
an increase in the amplification
efficiency
in the in the readout of the flu reset
through fluorescence information
during these days we use cyber green
essays the
gene doesn't matter but this was very
reproducible and if you summarize this
data
you see here the white and the
transparent plate that
is that the white plate receive a much
earlier crossing point of
more than one cycle earlier i have to
say these were all performed in one
block at the same time with the same
reactions and the one
and also the standard error here in the
white pit is slightly
uh smaller than in the transport rate
and we of
what we further analyzed here is the
difference between heat sealing and
adhesive sealing
you know these are differences and again
the the heat sealed
samples received lower errors so meaning
you can
you can you you really have an advantage
using
good consumables using white plates
using
a heat sealing this these results show
it very clearly
and uh at last slide we also
during these days we were thinking about
to to buy a robot uh uh okay it was
during these days it was very expensive
and therefore we made uh uh
experiments uh where we tested our hand
pipetting and this is a plate
which we analyzed with a with a with a
software of our former phd instead and
for me it's all sticker pad
but what you see here is more or less as
the differences
in hands pivoting over a 96 well played
we were we were not using eight channels
peppered with a single channel
paper single channel pipette all is the
same concentration what you hear sees
the size of the rings
either it's underestimated it's a red
color overestimated is the green color
and what you see here the excess is more
or less significant
from all the other significant
differences from all the other
results and you clearly see that you
have a significant
out layer in these border
areas this is we all know this that
we have these uh border effects on
plates
independent of any essay worldwide but
this should a little bit depict
uh the significance of maybe using a
robot
okay so this is just uh
to keep you thinking about
reproducibility
in plate setup okay uh let's come to the
end this was just an introduction about
the importance of mikey guidelines and
hence i want to point out
of our uh mikey qpcri book and i have to
say that since this week
we have the fourth edition online since
mondays this week
you can download it this is a free book
uh we have it now
on the market since about five years we
have
20 chapters in this book and uh
the title is how to apply the myki
guidelines a visual and interactive
practical qpcr guide you can download it
for free
we have a lot of chapters in and of
course one chapter is about
uh cool pcr consumables and this was
more or less written by the eppendorf
team by the coasters and co-speakers as
well from today
from raphael and from muriel and with
this
slide are gonna hand over uh to my
co-speakers thank you for your attention
and have fun during this webinar
yeah thank you michael for this very
interesting insight into the mic
guidelines as well as the
experimental data on how consumables can
influence the outcome of qpcr
experiments so
i will take over from here and
in my my first slide um
i i would like to to take to take a step
back
because uh when i thinking back at my
times working in the lab and
doing essays of some sort it might have
been qpcr but it could technically be
anything else
and when the experiment was not working
you go back and you do a lot of
troubleshooting
and um i i was thinking about a lot of
things right so first of all
uh you think about yourself you think
about the the sample handling the
preparation
then you question maybe the samples
itself so are these quality samples
maybe something went wrong
with the samples while processing it
then another big factor is reagents
so are the reagents still okay
have they been frozen correctly and of
course you are also thinking about the
lab equipment if you do
any measurements is the pipeline
calibrated correctly stuff like that
but another important influence on
essays that is often overlooked is the
actual consumables because
technically there is no essay which does
not get in contact with consumables of
any sort
most of those consumables are made out
of plastics
of course there are some made out of
glass but most of them are made out of
plastics
and during this webinar we will take a
closer look
at that plastic does not equal plastic
and how they can
influence the outcome especially
of qpcr
results so as i said consumables
are in in technically all the workflows
and
the reason what makes them very
influential
is that they are obviously always in
direct contact with the sample or with
the
with the reaction mix itself
and by such can directly influence vital
parameters
and consequently the performance of all
your experiments
so a high quality consumable
assures high quality and
also reproducible results obviously so
if i talk about consumables which is
like a very broad term
what consumables am i referring to so
and
if i break it down to a classical qpcr
workflow
we could say that okay the classical
consumables that
i think all of you are using in your
workflows are
some sort of tips for the pipetting no
matter if you do it
manually or automated you will always
use some sort of tips
then you are using single tubes
of different sizes depicted here
some of you will likely use tube strips
i think most of you are are using some
sort of plate
and i think that also a lot of you
listening are are using seals
so this is a overview
of the the most common format if we talk
format
i do i will take a little x curse here
in terms of
of nomenclature not necessarily only
important for qpcr
but in general because when i came to
eppendorf
and when people were talking to me about
consumables
sometimes i was lost with the let's say
vocabulary
so i wanna especially for the place i
wanna give you a little bit of a deeper
insight here because um plates uh
are usually divided into several type
plates of course there are pc operates
they can have different formats
um usually 96 well sometimes 384 well
then there are plates which have which
take a larger volume these are those um
like let's call it bigger plates and
those are called deep well plates or in
short
dvp and then we have um
so-called microtiter plates or
um mtp plates sometimes also called just
a micro plate
um so those are um plates
which are can take a lower volume than
deep well plates but which are
classically also not pcr plates so
for deep well plates and and micro
tighter plates um there are
um different so-called well shapes
and you might have seen that already so
there is the so-called flat bottom
this is uh for most of the elisa plates
which aren't used they have a flat
bottom
and then we have a round bottom
and so-called v-shape and
depending on the application it might
make sense to use
a plate with the correct bottom
the pcr plates usually do not come with
a different bottom shape so they have a
like adjusted v-shape so to speak um
they are they always have this this pcr
um plate shape so um that was a little
egg curse um just that you know what i'm
talking about if i say dvp or deep well
played
that we are on the same line here so but
as i said um so what i did before is i
was breaking down the consumables
um related to their format but
that might not be the best way to look
at the
performance criteria for consumables if
you look at a certain workflow
so um the better way is to
break down the consumables and to sort
them to the
actual workflow stats so if we look at a
qpcr workflow there are
consumables which are holding your
samples and reagents
and these are mostly
single tubes of a larger format
so starting from 1.5 ml usually
up to maybe even 15 ml
tubes if you have a lot of reagent
and then there are plates
these can be pcr plates micro tighter
plates or deep well plates but
what is in common is that these are
vessels which are mainly used for
storage and often also long-term storage
of reagents and samples
in in the freezer or in any environment
and then on the other side there are the
plates and vessels which are mostly only
used for a short time so for the sa
itself
and those are single tubes strips
and clay which of different formats
and what happens in those things is that
the the actual setup of the
essay has been done in those vessels um
as well as the readout and since the
readout is involved there as well
i put fields there as well because there
is especially for plates
and there is a need to close them if
they go into a qpcr cycler and
the connecting sector is the tips so
with the tips you are connecting the
vessels which are holding your samples
and reagents
with the vessels where you do your
actual essay
so and by the nature of these different
tasks
um there is there are different
prerequisites for those consumables
so consumables which are holding
samples and reagents especially for
long-term storage
one of the most important thing is that
they ensure sample integrity
so you don't want your pressure sample
to be lost during the storage process
then of course um there is
the sample safety in terms of in terms
of processing
um i think all of you know for example
if we talk about single tubes if you
want to spin
down the sample um this this tube is
better be
centrifugation stable i remember a
wonderful episode
from my study times uh in a test lab
where a whole batch of tubes more or
less
exploded in the centrifuge filled with
blood it was big fun to clean that up
and you want to also ensure in those
storage related vessels that you have
maximum
sample or reagent recovery so you don't
want to lose any of your pressure sample
or reagent to the vessel itself
user safety is important especially if
dealing with hazardous material and of
course you want to have a good handling
ideally
you want to have a good handling with
one hand and you also want to have a
good
tracking of your samples if we talk
about plates
okay if if we look at the if we look at
the tips
i think first and foremost thing is
precision so if you want to do a q pcr
setup um and if we talk manually but
also in a
in a automated fashion of course you
want to pipe at the correct volumes
so um the first thing that you want your
tip to be is
ensure maximum precision and accuracy
when it comes to pipetting
then of course it's sample safety so
cross-contamination is i guess the
biggest enemy of every qpcr experiment
and you want to have also sample and
reagent recovery
and as i will not do a deep dive into
tips um
two two things that i want to say here
is
of course it is extremely important the
combination between tip and pipette
so if you have tip and pipette uh
from the same manufacturer usually
you have the the best system which
ensures maximum
pressure precision and in terms of
cross-contamination
um i was always a big fan of using
uh filter tips for all my qpcr
experiments all right um and if we
if we talk about the final essay itself
about the
about the fa vessels uh of course you
want to have
uh optimum essay results
which means you want to have optical
brilliance
for the for the readout um but you also
want to have very good um heat transfer
so that the cycling works very well for
your qpcr experiments
um as well as easy and safe handling
uh during the during the essay setup
and of course um usually a qpcr
experiment is not done in a vacuum so it
usually doesn't end with a single qpcr
experiment
we all know working in the lab that
there is more than one experiment needed
there are subsequent experiments needed
experiment lines
so ideally you want all of those
consumables to have
the same quality the same performance
for each and every experiment so one
common thing you want to have for all of
those things is
that you have um an optimized let's say
and very reliable
um batch to batch consistency so if you
if you get one batch of plates you want
to you want them to perform the exactly
the same like the one you used a month
before
okay so and um since
the the the qpcr plate
is i think the thing that uh
what i see is as mostly used during qpcr
experiment what i want to do is i want
to
describe in in my view the the perfect
qpcr plate of course this um
this differs um uh depending on the
experimental
um setup um but uh ideally
um the plate has a solid polycarbonate
frame
which was an easy to read engraving
so that you can see okay what is my
position d7
without taking ages to find
the column and the row um
your plate um as if we if we
talk about handling um should have a
uh envy slash format um that is a
standard thing
if you ask yourself while all why all of
those plates six well played 24 well
played for the eight well played
they all have the same format is that
they have the so-called and the slash
format
if you have plates in this format this
makes them
compatible with most of the systems out
there with most of the instruments
and uh it's also very automation
friendly
which leads to the barcode so more and
more
stuff currently getting barcoded
especially if we talk about high
throughput
so um ideally you want to have a barcode
option
for a for a plate so if we talk about um
the the well um what is very important
there is you that you want to have a
well which is very thin
walled so which ensures optimal
heat transfer so that that the cycling
is fast and precise and
professor fussell already introduced the
difference
and the performance between a clear or
a white plate and he clearly pointed out
that
if you have the option to go for a white
plate a white plate will
usually give you a much better
performance
if you have a very stable and solid qpcr
protocol
and also expecting a large signal
intensity
you can obviously also go with the clear
plate just make sure
that it is has optical brilliance and
high quality so and as you can see
um these are like different
parameters for the plate frame and
the plate well which cannot achieved
with
the same type of plastic so this is why
i am a big fan
of a plate made of two components
for appendoff these are the so-called
twin tech plates so they come with a
polycarbonate frame which is very rigid
which is very
strong so it can be it can withstand
heat it's not
warping it's not shifting but it comes
with a polypropylene well
and this polypropylene well ensures
perfect
heat transfer and very fast pcr runs
right then a lot of you might have seen
very
different mpcr plates again talking a
little bit
about nomenclature here you you can see
three plates there from
top to bottom on the top so the first
plate is the so-called non-skirted plate
and then we have the semi-skirted plate
and the fully skirted plate
um what place you're going to use is
usually dictated by your qpcr
instrument or also by your pcr
instrument depending on
on what you're doing i
usually it's best if you have obviously
an instrument which can take all of
those plates
the difference between those plates is
usually the volume that you can use with
those plates
but there are some general things that
you have to keep in mind
um and i've listed this as grippable and
stackable
so with grippable i mean grippable by a
robot arm
not by a human hand obviously a human
hand can
work with all of those plates so a
non-skirted plate
the grip ability is very limited um by
pipetting robots and those plates are
obviously not stackable with stackable i
mean
if you put two of those plates on top of
each other
can you build a stack without
having any problems and risking your
your sample then we have a so-called
semi-skirted plate
so this has a little bit of a bigger
frame and this plate is perfectly
grippable but not really stackable
and then we have a so-called fully
skirted plate
and those plates are both um they are
grippable
and stackable and then sometimes you
come across the term high profile
and low profile plates so this basically
means the
the the geometry of the well and it's
actually pretty easy to
to remember when to use what a high
profile plate is usually used for high
volumes and the low profile
plate is usually used for low volumes
so with this short introduction
i hope i can help you to choose the
perfect upcr plate
for your essay i know that lab reality
um dictates uh that there's usually of a
mix of consumables within a lab and
some consumables are um of
uh of of very high quality and some
consumables
are of a little bit of a lower quality
so i can always encourage you to to mix
and match
make up your mind what is the most
important step
of my workflow what is uh what
should how should the consumables
perform for this step and then i'm going
to choose
um the my highest quality consumable for
the most important step
um obviously being consistent between
experiments so not swapping your plate
for every experiment because this can
have
influences uh on your results
um and i also want to end with one tip
um
for for plate um ceiling because
i was always encountering some problems
with plate ceilings so my tip is that if
you want to store a plate
use foil like this silverish
aluminium looking foil for long-term
storage
and use film which is clear
for for the for detection if you run an
experiment a reason behind this is
you want a clear film and to get perfect
qpcr results
but the foil is better suited for
long-term storage
because it is piercible you can just
pierce through with a pipette get to
your samples if you always want to
remove your film
it will most likely you will most likely
end up with cross-contamination
okay and before i hand over to rafal um
as we
at appendor we uh are constantly trying
to improve
our products um i have two questions for
you which help us to
make our products better um the first
one
is um are you doing your qpcr setup
manually
or automated um
are you doing your qpcr setup manually
or automated
manual are you doing it manual but you
want to automate it
or you do your qpcr setup
fully automated just quickly
repeat the question are you doing your
qpcr setup manually or automated
the answer options are manual manually
but i want to automate or fully automate
it
and i will give a couple of
seconds maybe one or two minutes for you
to
to answer the questions um and we are
very grateful
that you participate here and that you
give us your your answer because um
that really helps us to improve
products and also develop new products
all right um we have a lot of answers
coming in
um and for those of you who are
interested uh in the audience
most of the people are doing a a manual
cue pcr but
among them there is quite a number who
are thinking
about automation which is
obviously a very smart move as also
professor puffle pointed out
all right okay so thank you for that
and then we have a quick um second poll
and that leads me to something i've
discussed already
um is would you consider the ceiling of
plates
as an error-prone step in your workflow
so
would you consider the ceiling of plates
as an error-prone step in your workflow
the answers are no i hardly have
difficulties with sealing
yes the ceiling often causes trouble
or i do not seal my plate
so i will read the question one more
time
would you consider the sealing of plates
as an error prone step in your workflow
no i hardly have difficulties with the
ceiling yes the ceiling often causes
troubles
or i do not feel my place
again thank you for every one of you out
there
answering those questions it really
helps us
to get better
there's a few more answers coming in
thank you for that
um so it feels like there's a little bit
of a 50-50 situation here
um between
people thinking that um sealing is an
issue or is sometimes an issue
and those who are fine with their
sealing technique
all right thank you very much with that
i hope i could give you um a quick
insight in consumables for qpcr and with
this i'm going to hand
over to my lovely colleague rafa um
for more topics all right team thanks a
lot
um glad to be here hope everyone is
still awake
and um it's indeed a lot of stuff and
it's a lot of
important informations we just received
from professor huffle and
tim i'd like to dive in a little bit
more
into detail into the world of uh
plastics
and i'll show you probably some
interesting
and new data for you about how actually
the very properties of the materials the
quality of material
may influence of the plastics may
influence the qpcr
essays i will talk mainly about
leachables
probably topic already heard by some of
you
and uh unspecific sample laws
so let's go directly uh to the slides as
you see
um this is already what tim has talked
about
plastics have direct influence on the
essays
and there is a lot of different aspects
of uh
plastics which might be taken into the
consideration
uh so basically this material and
production process
quality control purity grades mechanical
features which we all
also lead centrifugation stability but
also smart features
low binds i will talk in my slide
predominantly about the first
so the material and the last the smart
features
and all of these parameters have a
dramatic impact on the sample
safety reliability of the experiments
and finally cost and time
and by the way we will provide you
basically this presentation in detail
so probably as pdf or also as a
recording so all of the details
which we will not or did not talk about
uh you will still have chance to to have
your own copy and go into the detail if
you wish
so um some important definitions of this
at the beginning
um legibles are basically chemical
substances which
are in the material and uh released
under specific
experimental conditions from the
consumable into the sample
reagent or essay and this conditions
vary from experiments to experiments
so obviously you have different amounts
in different compositions
of leachables in your reactions or
samples dependent on the
experiment and examples here are for
example leaching from
microcentrifuge tube into stored dna
sample
which might which may increase during
centrifugation because the tubes heat up
or under physical
stress but also during the storage and
another example is switching from pcr
plates
into qpcr reaction the plates are being
heated up and cooled down
in many cycles and as you will see
actually i provide some examples
on this it may produce legibles
in your reaction and there is
a similar term being often used these
are the extractables they're used
often in biotech and pharma areas
and these are the maximum amount of all
of the substances which can
be leached or extracted into the sample
so this is the worst case scenario
typically in life science fields they're
not really relevant
so legibles got attention in the recent
years from scientific community there
have been
a lot of different articles in the good
journals in nature
in science and basically the importance
of
literatures was largely underestimated
by the researchers so most of the
scientists knew there is a certain
impact
of consumables on the experiments but
did not
that they actually underestimated the
magnitude of these effects
and there these all of these papers
basically emphasized
growing importance of consumables
in hampering the experimental results in
spoiling the
the experiments and leading to change in
generally in changing perception where
high quality consumers
are increasingly important in the
experiments particularly
sensitive essays and qpcr is one of
those
examples so let's show some data
here we have a nice article
from biotechnics published by luis and
his team
team and what he did actually is very
simple
he took two uh 0.2 milliliter pcr
tubes and incubate into just water was
cycled
as a normal pcr reaction so 30 seconds
95
then 60 degrees 30 seconds in elongation
um
60 seconds and astonishingly what he
has have seen is when you put this water
samples into biospectrometer
t-thousand spectra and these uh
litchables
strongly uh resemble nuclear acids they
have very nice
peaks at let's say 260 the type 2
curve and this type 1 is a little bit
earlier
but both substances basically could be
mistaken by
for being nuclear acids we took this
experiment
and kind of wanted to quantify this
effect
and this is what you see here in the
first
panel above is the absorption spectrum
of water samples incubated in conical
tubes
just for 30 minutes and you have
different um different tubes from
different manufacturers producing
quite uh astonishingly
high amounts of fake dna so basically
this uh
is not the dna what you see here or
nucleic acids in general
but it's just the leachables which
absorb in this
in a very similar um region then as
nucleic acids
we quantified this fake dna in the tubes
and basically here what you see
and the panel below is the fake dna
concentrations in conical tubes
taken from the curves above and these
amounts are pretty
substantial we can go up to five or even
above
five micrograms per milliliter so of
course
it will influence downstream
applications when you do pcr or when you
purify
nucleic acids and you see fake dna it
will dramatically influence
the the downstream steps we took it
next level and we we asked the question
how um
this house leaching doing in plates
because uh plates you have many wells at
once and basically there are two
problems the amount of the leachables
per se and the variability of variance
between the walls and this is what you
see
here in panel a we
[Music]
plotted here the average spectra
obtained from three independent plates
so it's the average
um spectrum from different from the
three different plates
and you see in general high average
levels
of leachables we incubated just for
30 minutes 95 degrees and this is
already quite
um high amounts of leachables and
what is however much more important is
that the variance
between the wells is extremely high so
below you
you see as a controller we always use
our ependroplate which is
very low in leaching and here's an
example of
a plate a for one manufacturer and
what is clear here is there's a high
variance of leachable levels between
individual wells and this is something
when you
speak about all essays actually which
take place
in place and also qpcr is something
which you have
you would have a nightmarish drop
because um
one of the aspects is that qpcr and nfc
in a play format relies on the
fact that you have different samples in
different wells and
you rely on controls you rely on
standards and different play
wells and also the measurement has to be
reproducible and not um influenced by
any other factors
and what you see here there is a
dramatic influence on the position of
the well
dependent on the different plates
so basically there is a huge factor
increasing the variability in your
essays
in the played format
there is there has been a lot of buzz
about
leachables and there is just a little
extract of different papers
where we have the the author the
publication which
consumables have been shown to be uh to
have influence
on different legible types
and affected essay and basically what we
see here
there's a lot of ligands binding essays
there is the
enzymatic case there is also calculator
graph or cell culture essays also this
simple photometric dna or rna
quantification and what i wanted to
stress here is actually there are two
classes of legibles which are critical
and these are
red or yellow and in the next line
i will um i'm basically showing those
three classes so basically
and to nail it and to tell you the truth
all of these additives are being
predominantly using during the
production process of consumables
simply to alter the properties or to
reduce the production costs to make it
faster to make it cheaper
and these three classes so the
uncritical
have to be added during the production
process or during the polymerization
of the material otherwise you will not
have stable
polymer and these are the heavy metals
stabilizers
and antioxidants also pigments in case
of
colorful consumables the second
class is potentially critical it's the
clarifiers
antistatic agents and surfactants and
the third
the most critical
which have been shown in the literature
to be
responsible for most of the negative
effects is
the slip agents biocides and
plasticizers and these
two classes actually this is good news
can be
predom can be largely uh avoided during
the production
process so they don't have to be present
in in the tube or in the plate
and basically the recommendation the
first one
is in red strictly
be aware of this of the topic of
legibles and
try to purchase consumables which are
free of the critical additives so slip
agents bioscience and plasticizers
and ask their respective certificate and
of course
all around it it goes in the direction
of the
high quality pure consumables so the
clean room conditions and out high
levels of automation have to be used for
production of
consumables high quality raw materials
are not recycled
without extra additives has to be used
and my personal recommendation is
whenever you can and
it's necessary choose clear
or white consumables and also ask the
vendors
the manufacturers of the consumables for
plot specific certificates
used done by the external laboratories
and also consider always smart
consumables low retention and low blind
as we'll see in the next slide
so just to take a message here is the
topic of leachables be aware
there are substances going out of the uh
i'll go back to this slide
and be aware that these substances may
dramatically influence your experiments
qpcr is definitely one of those
essays and be aware of this
and choose consumables which are
certified free of these substances
now there is another topic i would like
to talk about is
a specific sample loss not many people
are aware of this
let's start with the lower attention and
basically
what you see here is a pretty common
situation you pipe at your master mix
for
qpcr or pcr and you always
calculate a little bit excess let's say
10 20
and this is due because um detergent
containing or viscous liquids
which is exactly the master mix
polymerase or pcr
reagents have tendency to remain in the
tip
and this sample retention can sum up up
to 20 30 percent loss of your
reagents and samples but even worse than
that
it might contribute to the huge
pipetting errors so the liquid retention
in your tips are cumulative and
basically can
cause that your pipette your pipette and
the tip
will be severely out of uh
specifications so
perform much below the specified
parameters
and by this compromise of course the
precision and reproducibility
of your essay and
to basically address this issue we
invented something which we call a low
retention
material at epeptendorf it's ultra
hydrophobic treatment
basically increases as you see here in
this molecular picture
let's say or rendering increases the
surface tension
and basically allows absolutely free
retention free pipetting of difficult uh
liquids
and this is what you see here is the
standard tip here the lower retention
table basically
completely went out of the tip and so
this may
dramatically improve the performance of
sensitive
pcr and real-time pcr reactions
ngs library preparations but also
sensitive diagnostic procedures
including the hot topic coronavirus
protocols
so remember guys sensitive essays always
use lower attention consumables
lower attention tips
[Music]
i will go perhaps to the video which
basically
shows you nicely how does it work if you
just click in the middle
i hope it will work on the play button
you will see
how it works i hope it will be possible
so just click in the middle
and let's see when my side is still
working
basically you see on the left side
conventional tip and there was a huge
retention
of the liquid on the right side there is
lower tension
and there is all of the liquid has been
removed
and this is what happens on the
molecular level
um as you see on the right tip
this high the lower retention surface
basically
is not getting in contact with the
liquid
all right i hope
i hope you enjoyed the little video so
uh let's go to the next slide
we quantified this effect and pipetted
simply water
in different tips from different
manufacturers and measured how much
water is being remained in the tip and
this effects are pretty
pretty strong here so we have different
different manufacturers
in some cases it's going above up to 30
0 30 microliters so
uh these effects are pretty large
and i have another example here where we
compare low retention tips to different
tips in different volumes
and as you see the the blue bars is the
larger uh
tip larger volume and the magenta
is lower and this effects are much
higher for the lower tips
and this has direct relevance and here
for the pcr here we were dispensing pcr
buffer
one percent sds and you see the bars
are really high for the low uh volume
shift so 10
microliter tips which is actually
nowadays pretty
often used pipetting the qpcr reaction
since the trend is to
lower the volume of the reaction
and here lower retention tips both
volumes are very low
volumes retaining in the tip so this is
basically
um we were talking about the lower
retention
last but not least low binds and this is
something not most of the people are not
really aware of
just in analytics perhaps or in high-end
laboratories
what is happening is the biological
material the biomolecules
are basically swimming happily in the
aqueous solutions they're covered by the
water sheath
water layer and outside the hydrophilic
and inside hydrophobic domains and what
happens when you put those
little happy molecules into the standard
polypropylene which is highly
hydrophobic
is basically they bind so you have
sample loss but also
denaturation and loss of activity and
this happens all the time
in all of the life science experiments
so we addressed this issue with
ultra hydrophilic polymer but basically
the molecules are prevented from binding
to
to the plastics by the layer of water
molecules
and this prevents them specific binding
and also
maximizes the sample recovery and
activity
of your samples it's very important for
low
volume or low concentration of your
samples which in many cases for example
in diagnostic samples
is is really important
and again a little video to show you how
actually
this works on the molecular level if you
just click in the middle
and this film will start
so we have standard polypropylene tubes
it refers both to protein and
nucleic acids so the tubes
can bind both types of molecules
and we have two distinct materials
addressing this
the nuclear acids and the protein
samples so here you have the protein
samples being
absorbed or
to the law to the wall of the tube here
the dna
and here is the low bind material which
which are the molecular level what is
happening
again dna and proteins and pcr clean so
basically all of the lobin consumables
are pcr clean
and this is what i mentioned the water
molecules prevent from binding the
proteins into the surface and the same
for the dna molecules
this increases dramatically the recovery
rate and basically assures that
activity of the biomolecules is
maintained
all right so this was the little film
and i'll show some data so here we start
protein samples were resting labeled bsa
in different tubes and over the course
of 96
hours you see the concentration in
eppendorf global tubes is pretty stable
at the same time in most of the tubes
you wouldn't already twins
the first 24 hours is really dropping
down and
you have basically most of the sample is
being absorbed
to the tube this effect is even more
dramatic
due to the surface to volume ratio in
plates and here we show the data from
384 well plates
for basically within first two four
hours
most of these samples in the case in
haste here the fluorescent label bsa are
being
unspecifically absorbed and lost um
to the to the experiments
just because uh it is in the well
made from standard polypropylene so this
unspecific absorption
can lead to dramatic decrease of the
sample
of the biomolecules which are available
for essay in the downstream applications
and so i think
this is the last slide so basically the
wrap-up and recommendations from my site
is choosing right consumers has dramatic
impacts
on the essays you perform consider
that these factors may really contribute
to increase the performance of your
experiments
so a lot of retention may increase the
worker disability
and reduce the loss of expensive
reagents it might
improve performance of pcr and real-time
pcr replica
applications low bind plastic
will decrease unspecific binding so
basically you will have maximized sample
recovery
in activity and finally regarding the
leachables
high quality consumables free of
critical additives may significantly
reduce
the risk and negative influence on the
experiments
that would be it from my side we're
already nine minutes over the time but i
think it was worth
for you staying with us and i give over
to tim and
professor hafel for final word
hello everybody i just want to
bring back slide number 16
if you're interested to download the
ibook
and i think i have to do this
with yeah here we are just click the
link
and you can download it for free
or you can also download on the on the
web page
uh a pdf version of the book if you
don't have any apple
devices so you have to log on to the
my key side and the my key site is
beyond a nice cartoon here
my kitchen quantification dot info is
there you can also find a link to a pdf
and now i hand over to the moderation
for the discussion i think thank you
very much
yeah um thank you everyone for staying
with us till the end um
i know that we did run over time a
little here
um i i appreciate all of you staying
with us um
i we there were a lot of questions
coming in through the webinar and we
are not able to answer all of them now
live
so um due to the advanced time i will
pick three questions
but be assured that we will answer all
of your questions via email
so you will receive an email answering
the questions that you've typed in
during this webinar
just give us a little time to to answer
to you so um the ques first questions
that we have here will go out to rafale
and it is um what is the difference
between the eppendorf protein lobin
tubes and the dna lobine can i use
protein lobin to do rna dna extraction
as well as all my qpcr or should it be
better to use the dna low bind range
yeah this is this is the
quite common question we always receive
um and there is the difference between
those two polymers so they are
specifically designed and optimized
for nucleic acids and protein slash
uh peptides samples so the low binds uh
dna low bind
will probably will have effects in
for storage of dna samples so i would
definitely use dna low bind
for storing um your material and also
when you have very
diluted samples so for example we very
much recommend dna lobin
for forensic applications uh in case of
qpcr i would say
protein low binds might have better
blends of properties and what we have
seen is that using protein-load binds in
ptr qpcr
sometimes performs even better than dna
load binds
and there is the reason for that the
protein load point has
to some extent dna lobby properties and
of course the
the proteins remain intact so since the
qpcr
and ptr is pretty complex reactions when
you have both
i would probably if i would recommend
and choose one i would stick to the
protein or bind
all right thank you for that rafal
um the the second question is directed
to
a professor suffer so what trouble
should
shooting should we do if we have big
spread results
for only one gene in the plate uh
it is a pcrt for gene expression
uh it should
yeah if you only have one gene uh in the
plate uh which has a huge variation all
the other genes
work perfectly well it couldn't be uh
due to the plastic of course uh it also
tells us
that the reagents are working because
some genes have low spread
hence have nothing to do with the
platform with the plastics with the
consumables at
all the big spread for one gene could
only be a
a problem of prima design meaning that
the primer did not fit perfectly
or there are mismatches in the primer
sequences and hence you got a big spread
from
for this particular gene
okay um thank you for that um
and i i will personally um
answer the the last question um
and it is uh why is the white plate
better than a clear plate in its
performance
is there any reason behind it or is it
just experimental observation
yes there is a reason behind it it is
not just experimental observation the
reason behind it is
if you have um a white white plate with
a white well if you think about a qpcr
cycle
usually the excitation with
with the laser as well as the readout is
from the top
so basically if you have a white
a white well a hundred percent of the
emitted light due to the excitation um
will be emitted in only one possible
direction which is
top so you will get the
maximum signal recovery
and signal strength so to speak and
a second a second reason why white
plates are performing better um
this is in in some cases and um it's not
true for all qcq pcr machines it's that
if you have a white plate you don't have
let's say
a leakage of the fluorescent signal
between two wells so you only get the
fluorescent signal
from one and uh from one well and not
from the neighboring worlds i do hope
this answers the question
as well um i apologize that this time we
can only keep it
two three questions there are a lot of
other really brilliant questions
um we have here but as i promised we
will answer all of your questions
via email with that also i will say
goodbye
i thank you for your attendance and i'm
handing
back to chrissy
thank you and thank you doctors for this
valuable information you provided us
today
it definitely prompted some interesting
questions now
i do want to remind our audience we had
quite a few questions that we were
unable to answer
those questions will be answered don't
fret they will be answered though via
the email
address you provided at the time of
registration
now i want to thank again dr tim
schumacher dr poffel
dr gerstiek excuse me gerschke weak
um gentlemen do you have any final
comments for our audience
let me start i really appreciated it it
was very interesting
as well for me to learn about the impact
of consumables
and also from from the eppendorf team
and
yes it was great i think also from my
side thanks a lot
and just to remember about consumables
and i basically send you warm greetings
from hamburg and stay healthy
so then i um i go last i can
i can just also say thank you for
attending this webinar
um i hope all of you are are safe
and and healthy um i wish you a great
rest of the week and if you have
any questions regarding consumables or
any other eppendorf
related products or workflows do not
hesitate to contact
us anytime you can find contact
information
on www.eppendorf.com
thank you thank you
a final huge thank you out to our
speakers dr
tim shawmarts dr michael poffel and dr
rossell gorskubiak thank you for your
time today
we'd also like to thank labyrinth and
our sponsor eppendorf for underwriting
today's educational webcast
today's webcast can be viewed on demand
and labrets will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
in that email you will also find a link
where you can download your certificate
for attendance if you would need
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues as well who may have
missed today's live event
that's all thank you for joining us we
hope you stay safe and healthy
have a great day
you